uh have you haven't done the the Ringo
shows yet or have you we did this
weekend yeah and what is hila is he
still enjoying his
81 or 82 and does jumping jacks he is
light on his feet
he I mean he runs out on stage
and he runs off the stage and he and he
plays drums like like he's 25. wow it's
it's uh
is exciting to watch him to say that
this is possible
this is possible and he exudes gratitude
and joy
and you sense that and I know he's been
through a lot of a lot of tough things
and you I just sense that like whatever
because again with the Beatles like they
were the only four people experienced
that
and it was isolating and it was
difficult
you know it was a blessing but it was
also a curse and they all they all had
things they had to go through in their
life after that and um
he is strikes me as being uh reconciled
with it and
grateful for it and he I sense he feels
blessed to be doing what he's doing
today so he he exudes Something
Beautiful
do they play Octopus's Garden
ah in this I don't think they actually
played it in the set so it's all stars
so it's like Colin Hay from Men at Work
plays one guitar the great Steve
lukather who was in Toto plays the other
like probably one of the greatest guitar
players in the history of Music this guy
he Thriller album like Toto was the band
for the Thriller album like we can't
forget that like Toto wrote you I never
knew that yeah yeah yeah
wow incredible but just uh so so they do
like hold the line Rosanna and Africa
and they do
um
the bass player for The Average White
Band so they do one of those great funky
instrumentals
um is it Edgar Winter plays the piano
Johnny Winter past play guitar I think
Edward Edgar Winter plays piano if I get
that wrong I'm so sorry but so they do
free ride
which everybody knows Free Ride yeah of
course
um Frankenstein that great instrumental
Frankenstein
oh sure okay um okay so it's a great
show it's like the greatest cover band
and then Ringo does like photograph and
the encores uh With a Little Help from
your friends and and we all we got to go
up there and sing you know and yeah it
was just it was you know I'm convinced
like we've not won a Grammy
um uh we've won like some other Awards
but but like I think no matter how many
records we sell no matter what we
achieve as the Avett Brothers the most
Cherished Memories will be I'm gonna
name drop being on stage with Bob Dylan
at the Grammys you know recording with
Rick Rubin being on stage with Bob Weir
being on stage with Ringo like these
like little things that
don't make or break you
but they are the icing on the cake
they're just they're the Beautiful
Moments that that you just cherish yeah
wow what a great answer
[Music]